Star Wars has given us a lifetime of
unforgettable memories ethic buttons
iconic characters weapons and vehicles
that spark the imagination with Star
Wars Battlefront we will give you the
thrill of living out your Star Wars
battle fantasies in a game that has
death variety and is above all fun
fighting for survival alongside a friend
on Tatooine stepping into the boots of
an imperial soldier and crushing rebel
scum on Hoth or just living out the
ultimate Star Wars fantasy and becoming
one of the most iconic characters in the
Star Wars universe with Battlefront
we don't want you to just play out the
fantasies you've always had we want you
to create new moments you've never even
imagined and today we are unveiling
Fighter Squadron
a brand new 20 player multiplayer mode
inspired by the thrilling aerial comfort
scenes from the films now let's take to
the sky here's the world premiere of
Fighter Squadron in Star Wars
Battlefront
attention all fighters there's an
imperial transport attempting to escape
find the target and take it out
eriell transport
cannot be allowed to intercept this
transport insurance extraction
going in
always this is it take them out
we're pushing them back
do not relent show them the power of the
Empire
we're outnumbered
never tell me the odds
take it out
Thank You fighter squadron puts you
inside the cockpit of some of the most
iconic vehicles ever seen in the Star
Wars galaxy
x-wings a wings Tie Fighters and
interceptors and of course the
Millennium Falcon
these fast-paced aerial battles will
take you from the highest altitudes
above each planet all the way down to
frantic chases through dangerous terrain
and to make things even more epic there
will be an additional 20 AI star
fighters in in disguise adding even more
excitement to the battle all of this
combines to deliver the most intense
Star Wars dogfights ever in a video game
and for those of you here at Gamescom
you'll be able to play Fighter Squadron
this week for the very first time
you also saw all of the action taking
place from Sullust a previously
unexplored planet in the Star Wars
universe working closely with Lucasfilm
our team of dice have been given the
privilege of creating the visual
identity for Sullust as huge Star Wars
fans I can't tell you how honored our
team is to know that you will get your
first true look at Sullust in Star Wars
Battlefront and not only does it look
exciting
the gameplay is action pack from intense
dogfights to epic ground battles Sullust
provides a number of great locations
including lava filled landscapes and the
hangars where the Empire pits and houses
their war machines we have a loft left
to show you before star wars battlefront
launches this November including new
modes Maps characters and more until
then here's another look at just some of
the Star Wars battle fantasies that
await you thank you